let's talk now about Florida Florida is
a state where incumbent Republican
senator Marco Rubio is trying to Stave
off a challenge from a democratic
congresswoman Val demings if I voted in
Florida I would vote for deming's over
Marco Rubio Marco Rubio appeared on CNN
over the weekend he sounded very very
sick hopefully it's not coveted and just
a cold but he sounded ill and he was
confronted about the fact that in the
past he has voted against funding for
other states when they are hit with a
natural disaster but now he wants money
for Florida when it's his State
recovering from Hurricane Ian now to
remind everybody in my audience
I think they all should get the federal
funds for disaster relief but what we're
talking about here is hypocrisy now when
Dana Bash confronts Rubio with this
hypocrisy he tries to pull some weird
pork thing and Dana Bash good for her is
prepared for it and she calls it out for
the lie that it is check this out
Senator you wrote a letter Friday to the
Senate Appropriations Committee asking
for disaster relief dollars for
desperately needed resources to rebuild
Florida communities after Hurricane
Sandy hit Northeastern states in 2012
you voted no on a 50 billion dollar
relief package I know you supported a
smaller version but why should other
Senators vote for relief for your state
when you didn't vote for a package to
help theirs right oh I've always voted
for Hurricane and disaster relief I've
even voted for it without pay Force what
I didn't vote for at Sandy's because
they had included things like a roof for
a museum in Washington DC for Fisheries
in Alaska it had been loaded up with a
bunch of things that had nothing to do
with disaster relief and I wouldn't
support disaster relief efforts I would
never put out there that we should go
use a disaster relief package for
Florida as a way to pay for all kinds of
other things people want around the
country so I think that's the key in
moments like this and then Sandy
unfortunately loaded it up they really
did with a bunch of things that had
nothing to do with Sandy but get ready I
voted for every disaster relief package
especially that's clean and I'll
continue to do so when it comes to
Florida I'll do that again and we'll
make sure that that package is clean it
doesn't have stuff for other people in
there I read the Congressional research
service report last night it sounds like
that roof actually was damaged by the
hurricane and what happened in Alaska
was turns out it wasn't a random roof
Marco the result of another disaster but
in any event my question is about the
future are you telling me that if
hurricane Ian relief contains anything
that smells like pork you'll vote no
sure I'll fight against it having pork
in it oh well that's a different thing
you'll fight against it but you'll vote
for it in this particular case this is
not unique to Rubio not like in Rubio's
defense I mean we're talking about Rubio
because it's Florida he represents
Florida but this is really common over
the last decade on this program it's
been what a dozen times two dozen times
that I've come to you all with peace and
love and tears in my eyes and I've said
to you here is another elected official
from Oklahoma Oklahoma just got hit with
tornadoes this very same Oklahoma
official when it was super storm Sandy
affecting New York and New Jersey they
voted against it and now they're saying
give me the money please we need it for
the people these are hypocrites and
there's dozens of them and it's not
unique to Marco Rubio but Marco Rubio is
the guy running for reelection right now
and checking in on the polling there
it's not great but it's not terrible
Marco Rubio leading Val demings on
average by 2.8 percentage points Within
Reach Within Reach and of course all
these guys and I do mean Rubio and
DeSantis all of a sudden they're
friendly with Biden and they're all in
favor of relief because they don't want
to lose their office because of a
disastrous botched reaction to Hurricane
Ian that's their priority right now I've
seen several people in my life try to
quit smoking or vaping and quitting has
so many benefits but it does require a
strategy and our sponsor fume is a
one-of-a-kind inhaler that can help you
quit smoking as a replacement for the
hand-to-mouth habit of smoking there is
no smoke there is no vapor and there's
no nicotine fume is just a small inhaler
handcrafted from wood it uses core doors
infused with fresh aromatic plant oils
for you to taste and enjoy instead of a
nasty cigarette or a vape you can use
fume while flying which is a big plus
because there's no smoke no Vapor no
nicotine fume has flavors like
peppermint and Conquer with a powerful
minty sensation to simulate the menthol
cigarettes they have other flavors like
cozy chai I love chai myself and lemon
berry Bliss for a sweeter experience
fume has helped thousands of people quit
people who have tried everything else
read the reviews we talked to the fume
team they're very proud of the lives
that they've impacted throw out the
cigarettes get rid of the Vapes head
over to
breathefume.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman to get 10 off your entire order
the link is down below